To the Republican National Convention continued
yesterday, yesterday was day two.
It was definitely a different day than day
one.
There was less screaming from the speakers,
although Eric Trump did a little bit of screaming.
But it was sort of a weaker day from the standpoint
of making the case that Donald Trump should
be reelected.
Some of the major speeches yesterday, including
Melania Trump's, said a lot, but didn't actually
explain why what they said means or points
to reelecting Donald Trump.
And I'm going to get to that in a moment.
But if I had to sort of give a very broad
overview, day one was a radical screaming
Kimberly Guilfoyle, Donald Trump Junior, whereas
day two was more trying to be more precise,
trying to be more calm about the Trump administration
being a real administration, a respectable
administration and having earned four more
years, but failing to do so and not really
making that case.
And it also included dates who did some horrible
breaches of protocol, possibly even of the
law before day two, even started.
By the way, one of the speakers was removed
from a montage because it was revealed that
she previously tweeted anti-Semitic conspiracy.
Here he is.
This was Marianne Mendoza.
Her police officer son was tragically killed
by a drunk driver.
She was going to be included in a list of
speaker excerpts remarks.
And it became known that she had previously
retweeted a thread on Twitter promoting anti-Semitic
conspiracies.
So she was pulled from the evening program.
I mean, just every detail beyond parody and
exactly what the stereotypes about these types
of events are actually meeting that standard,
that expectation conforming to it.
Melania Trump spoke from the White House Rose
Garden now.
It was a Rose Garden devoid of roses.
Very strange updates to the landscaping made
in advance of Melania Trump's speech, which
shouldn't even have taken place, really.
The White House not supposed to be used as
a political prop, not supposed to be used
for political events.
And they did.
There will be no repercussions.
Don't even think about it.
I know it's frustrating, but there's just
not going to be any repercussions for that.
But the most notable thing to me from day
two was the degree
to which it was filled with bold faced lies,
provable lies.
And this was another distinction from day
one, not only less screaming on day to day
one, more optics and propaganda that are less
simply factually false.
Day one had a lot of North Korea like imagery
from Kimberly Guilfoyle.
Obviously nonsense, but not as many straight
up factual lies.
Yesterday was just laughable.
Obvious, provable, empirical lie after lie.
And we're going to go through some of them.
Maybe the funniest was when former Florida
Attorney General Pam Bondi claimed that what
she did as Florida attorney general was fight
corruption.
Check this out and then I'll remind you why
it's so wild that for Joe Biden, it's been
the land of opportunism, not opportunity.
As a career prosecutor and former attorney
general of Florida.
I fought corruption and I know what it looks
like, whether it's done by people wearing
pinstripe suits or orange jumpsuits.
Pam Bondi says that she fought corruption
as attorney general in Florida.
She was investigating Trump University as
attorney general in Florida.
Trump donated to her reelection campaign and
the investigation went away.
And she has the audacity to brazenly say that
she fought corruption as attorney general
in Florida.
She was corrupt as attorney general in Florida.
Pam Bondi also criticized Joe Biden for nepotism
and then was followed up yesterday by Tiffany
Trump.
Eric Trump and Melania Trump.
Again, Saturday Night Live can't do anything
with it.
It's beyond parody.
Tiffany Trump did speak, as I mentioned.
She's Donald Trump, sort of less public daughter.
It wasn't really clear.
It hasn't been clear that Tiffany Trump likes
her dad.
And it certainly wasn't clear yesterday.
But she did speak.
She bizarrely claimed that people are enslaved
by the media and coerced by the media and
by tech giants.
Very unusual imagery.
Take a look.
That's who we are voting for.
Name and are being manipulated and visibly
coerced by the media and tech giants.
If you tune into the media.
You get one guy's opinion or another.
And what you share, if it does not fit into
the narrative that they seek to promote, then
it is either ignored or deemed a lie.
Regardless of the truth, this manipulation
of what information we receive impedes our
freedoms rather than allowing Americans the
right to form our own beliefs.
This misinformation system has people mentally
enslaved, enslaved.
I mean, really powerful language.
Tiffany's speech, again, it wasn't just low
energy.
It didn't make the case for Donald Trump's
reelection.
And that was what was interesting, Abullah,
about a lot of the speeches yesterday, including
Melania's, which we're going to get to, which
was that so much was said, but it wasn't clear
why anybody should vote for Donald Trump on
the basis of the speeches that were made.
Trump's son, Eric Trump, spoke.
And again, lame lies, nonsense.
But here is one of the whoppers that Eric
told, just making things up out of thin air
in the Middle East.
Never any wars were finally ended.
Now, of course, Donald Trump did not achieve
peace in the Middle East.
You probably know that Donald Trump did not
end any wars.
You probably know that it just didn't happen.
These are provable empirical lies.
We then heard from
Trump economic adviser Larry Kudlow, who showed
up and just told a complete fantasy about
the Trump administration's handling of coronavirus.
And in that context, the economy.
Take a look at this one.
Once in 100 year pandemic.
It was awful.
Health and economic impacts were tragic.
Hardship and heartbreak were everywhere.
But presidential leadership came swiftly and
effectively with an extraordinary rescue for
health and safety to successfully fight the
cold virus.
So to his credit, Larry Kudlow didn't seem
drunk this time.
That's good.
But he wasn't making any sense anyway.
And of course, this administration did not
put together the brilliant health and economic
plan that Larry Kudlow wants us to believe
they put together.
And in fact, the Trump administration response
was one of the worst responses to the virus
in the world and led to not only unnecessary
death, but also unnecessary economic destruction.
They didn't create the virus.
They're not responsible for the virus, but
they are responsible for one of the worst
responses.
Larry Kudlow.
Also, by the way, as many speakers did on
day one and on day two, Kudlow refers to coronavirus
and the pandemic in the past tense.
You might be interested to know, just to be
anchored to reality, that Corona virus killed
another 12 hundred ninety one people in the
United
States yesterday alone.
They continue to pretend that it's over and
they need to.
They need to.
And that's why they've been doing it for months.
Coronavirus ranks as one of the most important
issues for voters and one of the ones where
Donald Trump has the lowest approval ratings.
So they have to pretend it's over.
They have to claim that Donald Trump managed
it very well.
Now, one of the propaganda elements that's
concerning many people from yesterday is that
uniformed members of the military were pulled
into the evening, which isn't supposed to
happen.
For example, we're showing video of uniformed
Marines.
When Donald Trump did a naturalization ceremony
at the White House for new citizens, Marines
and members of the military are not supposed
to be political figures in political videos.
And the entire night was filled with this.
Now, the response from the White House
was these events were White House formal events.
The video was then made public and the public
video was then used at the RNC.
So at the time that the uniformed Marines
were filmed, these were not political events,
but they were White House events.
I don't think I have to say too much more
about that reasoning.
Another propaganda element was Trump springing
a pardon on a guy after a whole propagandistic
montage.
And again, Donald Trump creating something
out of nothing.
Take a look at this video.
Listen to this.
To join us, as I grant John, I'm not sure
you know, there's a full pardon, so I don't
know if you know that, Jamie.
Come on over here.
It's just an honor.
And you have done incredible work.
Thank you, sir.
And all of Las Vegas, Nevada, and all of every
place in this country is very proud of the
job you've done, bringing people back.
And you.
Right.
We're supposed to be there for five minutes.
So state for an hour because it was so interesting
to me.
Congratulations.
You really get the sense that Donald Trump
doesn't really understand what he's doing,
but he imagines or envisions that it looks
great to people and that they're going to
be incredibly moved by it when it's just awkward
more than anything else.
And then the night capped off.
The keynote of the evening last night was
Melania Trump, a very long speech, completely
meandering.
If you said what was the speech about?
I couldn't tell you.
There was really no arc to it.
There was no coherent narrative.
And it certainly didn't make the case for
why Donald Trump should be reelected.
Donald Trump did not seem pleased during it.
In fact, as we're showing people, he looked
like very much like he was not enjoying himself
every time that the camera would cut to him
during the speech.
And it was a lame speech.
Here's a few moments,
Melania, saying that Donald Trump this is
funny, that Trump doesn't play politics and
even she seems to have a hard time believing
that Dawna's wants to keep your family safe.
He wants to help your family succeed.
He wants nothing more than for this country
to prosper.
And he doesn't waste time playing politics
now.
Oh, yeah.
What I didn't like was I saw a lot of people
supposedly on the left, for example, during
my live streams yesterday ridiculing Melania
for her accent.
Listen, she's not from the United States.
People have accents when they learn languages
as adults.
I do think it's beneath us to go after her
for her accent.
We should go after Donald Trump because he
has one position on immigration.
And then we learned that his wife was working
in the United States at a time when she was
not authorized to work in the United States.
That's against the law.
We.
That's fair game.
Melania's parents got special treatment and
became citizens.
Melania got an Einstein visa.
All of that is completely fair game.
Her accent is not fair game for me.
I think the left should stay away from that.
I think it does absolutely nothing for
us.
Now, here, Melania Trump seems to sort of.
Find the solution to racism in some weird
way.
Take a look with that in mind.
I like to call on the citizens of this country
to take a moment, pause and look at things
from all perspectives.
I urge people to come together in a civil
manner so we can work and live up to our standard
American ideals.
I also ask people to stop the violence and
looting being done in the name of justice
and never make assumptions based on the color
of a person's skin.
Yeah.
Guys, I mean, just stop the violence.
Stop the looting and stop the racism.
Wow.
All right.
And then again, how that links to Trump's
reelection is beyond me.
There were some really Cringely applause lines
where it sort of became clear that people
were supposed to clap, but always like half
a beat too late.
For example, Malani pausing when she said
that she became a citizen after passing a
test.
And it was just really, really awkward.
But I wanted more.
I wanted to be a citizen after 10 years of
paperwork and patients.
I studied for the test in 2006 and became
an American citizen.
So, again, the real critique of this speech
is there was no coherent story.
There was no coherent arc.
It was terribly written.
But more importantly, these musings from Melania
Trump don't make the case effectively for
Donald Trump's reelection.
Now, you and I would say you can't possibly
make that case because he doesn't deserve
to be reelected.
And I would agree with you.
But typically, no matter how bad a first term
has been, a convention speech is able to put
together a story, at least plausibly justifying
if you buy into it, the reelection of the
sitting president.
Melania's speech didn't even do that.
And quite frankly, for all we know, she doesn't
even want Donald Trump to be reelected.
My sense from day one has been she didn't
want to be the first lady of the United States.
She just wanted to marry a rich guy
and travel from penthouse to penthouse on
Trump's private plane.
I don't think she really wants any part of
this.
I don't think it's been particularly good
for her.
And again, yesterday, we learned that she
had been she has been caught on recordings
disparaging Donald Trump, disparaging Trump's
adult children.
It's not even clear she wanted to be giving
this speech, but it is what it is, I guess,
to quote Donald Trump.
Tonight is night three.
We're expecting scheduled, although always
subject to change.
If someone gets caught tweeting something
anti-Semitic, they may be pulled.
But we're expecting Vice President Mike Pence
tonight.
His wife, Karen Pence, a bunch of other members
of Congress, Kellyanne Conway, who recently
announced she's quitting in five days.
She's scheduled to speak tonight.
Eric Trump's wife, Lara. Trump expected tonight.
So join me for day three.
I'll be starting the live coverage
on our YouTube and Twitch channels at about
quarter past 8:00 p.m. Eastern time, 8:00,
15 p.m. Eastern, five, 15 p.m. Pacific, and
like 2:00 in the morning Western Europe time.
A lot of people staying up late with us for
these conventions.
Join me tonight.
In the meantime, let me know your thoughts
via Twitter.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
You can find me there.